So now let's see what happens when we try to do multiple predictions
simultaneously. Suppose we have the classical five stage pipeline with a fetch,
decode, ALU, memory, and write register stages, and
suppose that this is where our branches are resolved in the third stage.
Suppose also that we have the following program. A branch that jumps to
label A if registers R1 and R2 are not equal.
Another branch in the program right after it that compares R1 and R3 and
jumps to label B if they are not equal. Then we have some instruction A, B,
C that are not branches. And then we have label A where we have instructions
X and Y and we have then label B where we have instruction Z.
Suppose that we are using a not taken predictor and that this branch.
And also this branch, are taken, assuming that we start execution
right here. The question for you is, how many cycles are wasted on
mispredictions until we finally get to execute instruction Y,
because what should be happening is that we jump after this branch here and
execute x and y. What really happens is that, because of our not taken
prediction, we go on and actually fetch this branch instead. So again, how
many cycles are overall waited on mispredictions until we correctly get to Y?